ou mon cerveau qui déforme les données que mes yeux lui ont transmises ?
Depuis, je ne cesse de me demander
pourquoi nous ne voyons pas des soucoupes volantes dans le ciel.
Tout du moins,
pourquoi ne voyons-nous pas de vie dans le cosmos ?
C'est un mystère.
J'en discute avec des dizaines de spécialistes
de différentes formations depuis trente ans.
Il n'y a pas de consensus sur le sujet.
Frank Drake a commencé à chercher des signaux extraterrestres dès 1960.
Mais rien. Nada.
Avec chaque année qui passe,
cette non-observation,
ce manque de preuve d'une quelconque activité extraterrestre
devient de plus en plus intrigant car on devrait les détecter, non ?
L'univers est vieux de 13,8 milliards d'années,
plus ou moins.
Si nous représentons l'âge de l'univers sur une échelle d'un an,
notre espèce existe depuis minuit moins 12 minutes,
le 31 décembre.
La civilisation occidentale existe depuis quelques secondes.
Des civilisations extraterrestres auraient pu exister depuis l'été.
Imaginez une civilisation estivale
qui aurait développé une technologie plus avancée que la nôtre,
mais qui repose sur les lois de la physique -
je ne parle pas de trou de ver ou de distorsions du temps,
seulement l'extrapolation des technologies célébrées par TED.
Cette civilisation pourrait programmer des sondes auto-réplicantes
pour visiter tous les systèmes planétaires de la galaxie.
S'ils avaient lancé les premières sondes juste après minuit en août,
le lendemain, au petit-déjeuner,
ils auraient colonisé la galaxie.
La colonisation intergalactique est à peine plus compliquée.
Elle prend juste plus de temps.
Une civilisation venue de n'importe laquelle des millions de galaxies
aurait colonisé la nôtre.
Ça vous semble tiré par les cheveux ?
Peut-être
mais les extraterrestres n'auraient-ils pas des activités visibles,
des équipements autour d'étoiles pour capter l'énergie solaire,
des collaborations sur Wikipedia Galactica
ou simplement des appels dans l'univers : « Nous sommes là ! » ?
Où sont-ils tous ?
C'est un mystère car nous nous attendons à l'existence de ces civilisations.
Après tout, il y a plus de mille milliards de planètes dans la galaxie,
peut-être davantage.
Pas besoin de connaissance spéciale pour réfléchir à ce sujet.
J'ai exploré la question avec plein de gens pendant des années.
J'ai découvert qu'ils structurent souvent leur pensée
en termes d'obstacles à dépasser
pour qu'une planète accueille une civilisation qui communique.
Ils identifient quatre types d'obstacles.
L'habitabilité,
c'est le premier obstacle.
Notre planète doit se situer dans la zone exactement idéale
où l'eau coule sous forme liquide.
Il y en a.
En 2016, des astronomes ont confirmé qu'il y a une planète habitable
dans le système de l'étoile la plus proche
Proxima du Centaure,
si proche que le projet Breakthrough Starshot va y envoyer une sonde.
Bienvenue dans le monde de Starfaring.
Mais tous les mondes ne sont pas habitables.
Trop proches d'une étoile et nous grillons.
Trop éloignés d'une étoile et nous gelons.
L'abiogenèse,
la création de la vie à partir de matière non vivante,
est le deuxième obstacle.
Les éléments de base pour créer la vie ne sont pas uniques à la Terre :
on trouve des acides aminés dans des comètes,
des molécules organiques dans des nuages de poussière interstellaires
et de l'eau dans des systèmes exoplanétaires.
On a les ingrédients.
Mais on ne sait pas comment ils se combinent pour créer la vie
et il y a sans doute des mondes où la vie ne prend pas.
Le développement technologique est le troisième obstacle.
Certains disent que nous partageons déjà notre planète avec d'autres intelligences.
Une étude de 2011 montre que les éléphants coopérent pour résoudre des problèmes.
Une étude de 2010 montre
qu'un poulpe en captivité peut reconnaître des humains.
Une étude de 2017 montre que des corbeaux peuvent planifier l'avenir,
des animaux merveilleux et intelligents,
mais ils ne peuvent pas concevoir le projet Breakthrough Starshot.
Si nous disparaissions aujourd'hui,
ils ne nous remplaceraient pas pour le mettre en œuvre.
Pourquoi le feraient-ils ?
L'évolution n'a pas pour fin ultime la conquête de l'espace.
Il existe des mondes où la vie ne conduit pas à une technologie avancée.
La communication dans l'espace, tel est le quatrième obstacle.
Des civilisations avancées pourraient faire le choix d'explorer l'espace interne
aux dépens de l'espace,
ou s'intéresser aux petites distances et pas aux longues.
Elles pourraient simplement ne pas vouloir risquer
de rencontrer une civilisation potentiellement plus avancée et hostile.
Il y a des mondes où, pour une raison ou une autre,
les civilisations resteront silencieuses, ne passeront pas de temps à communiquer.
Quelle est la hauteur de ces obstacles ?
Personne ne le sait.
Par expérience,
quand on prend le temps de calculer,
on conclut typiquement qu'il y a des milliers de civilisations dans la galaxie.
Et on revient au point de départ : où sont les extraterrestres ?
Par définition,
les OVNI, même celui que j'ai vu,
sont non identifiés.
Impossible de déduire que c'est un vaisseau spatial.
On peut s'amuser un peu avec l'idée que des extraterrestres sont déjà là.
Certains affirment que la civilisation estivale a colonisé la galaxie
et a fertilisé la vie sur Terre.
D'autres affirment que nous vivons dans une réserve cosmique,
un zoo.
D'autres encore disent
que nous vivons dans une simulation
où les programmeurs n'ont pas encore activé les extraterrestres.
La plupart de mes collègues affirment toutefois que E.T. est là
et que nous devons continuer à le chercher.
Ça fait sens.
L'espace est vaste.
C'est difficile d'identifier un signal
et on n'observe pas depuis si longtemps.
Clairement, nous devons chercher davantage.
Il s'agit de comprendre notre place dans l'univers.
La question est trop importante pour être ignorée.
Mais il y a une réponse évidente :
nous sommes seuls.
Il n'y a que nous.
Il y a sans doute mille milliards de planètes dans la galaxie.
Est-ce plausible que nous soyons les seules créatures
capables de réfléchir à cette question ?
Eh bien, oui, car dans ce contexte,
qui sait si mille milliards est beaucoup ou pas ?
En 2000, Peter Ward et Don Brownlee ont proposé l'idée de Terre Rare.
Vous voyez ces quatre obstacles
évoqués par les gens pour estimer le nombre de civilisations ?
Ward and Brownlee pensent qu'il y en a plus.
Voici un obstacle possible.
C'est une suggestion récente de David Waltham,
un géophysicien.
Je vais vous esquisser ma version simplifiée
de la pensée sophistiquée de Dave.
Nous pouvons être ici maintenant
car les anciens habitants de la Terre ont bénéficié
d'un climat clément pendant quatre milliards d'années,
avec des hauts et des bas, mais clément.
La stabilité du climat sur le long terme est étrange
ne serait-ce qu'à cause des influences astronomiques
qui peuvent mener une planète à geler ou griller.
Il semble que la Lune a contribué à ça.
C'est intéressant
car la théorie qui prévaut
dit que la Lune existe depuis que Theia,
un objet de la taille de Mars,
a télescopé la Terre, nouvellement créée.
L'issue de ce crash aurait pu être très différente du système Terre-Lune.
Mais on a une grosse lune
qui a permis à la Terre d'avoir une inclinaison axiale stable
et une rotation lente.
Les deux facteurs influencent le climat
et on pense que ça a contribué à une modération du climat.
Super pour nous.
Mais Waltham montre que si la Lune avait été un rien plus grande,
la situation aurait été autre.
L'inclinaison axiale de la Terre varierait de manière chaotique
créant des épisodes de changement climatique rapide,
peu propice à une vie complexe.
La Lune a juste la bonne dimension :
grosse mais pas trop grosse.
Une lune idéale autour d'une planète idéale.
Un obstacle sans doute.
On peut songer à d'autres.
Par exemple,
des cellules simples sont venues à la vie il y a des milliards d'années,
mais peut-être que le développement d'une vie complexe
avait besoin d'une série d'événements improbables.
Une fois que la Terre a eu accès à la multicellularité,
aux structures génétiques sophistiquées,
et au sexe,
de nouvelles opportunités sont apparues :
les animaux.
Mais ça pourrait être le destin de nombreuses planètes
que d'accueillir une vie qui reste au niveau unicellulaire.
Pour compléter cette image,
je vais suggérer quatre autres obstacles
aux quatre obstacles qui empêchent une civilisation communicative.
C'est simplement pour illustrer le sujet.
Imaginez qu'elle ait une chance sur mille de dépasser chaque obstacle.
Il y a diverses manières de les contourner.
Et les chances pourraient être meilleures qu'une sur mille.
Il pourrait aussi y avoir plus d'obstacles
et les chances tombent à une sur un million.
Observons comment ça se traduit dans notre tableau.
S'il y a mille milliards de planètes dans la galaxie,
combien accueilleront une civilisation capable d'envisager, comme nous,
un projet comme Breakthrough Starshot ?
L'habitabilité,
la bonne planète autour de la bonne étoile,
de mille milliards, on passe à un milliard.
La stabilité,
un climat favorable pour l'éternité,
fait passer ce nombre à un million.
Si la vie commence,
on passe à mille planètes.
Pour qu'une vie complexe émerge,
de mille, on passe à une.
L'usage d'outils complexes ?
On parle d'une planète dans mille galaxies.
Pour comprendre l'univers,
il faut développer les sciences et les mathématiques,
on parle d'une planète pour un million de galaxies.
Pour atteindre les étoiles, il faut devenir des êtres sociaux,
capables de débattre de concepts abstraits
en utilisant une grammaire complexe.
Une planète sur un milliard de galaxies.
Il faut aussi éviter les catastrophes,
qu'elles soient auto-infligées ou naturelles.
Cette planète autour de Proxima du Centaure,
elle a explosé l'année dernière.
Une planète parmi mille milliards de galaxies,
dans l’univers visible.
Je pense que nous sommes seuls.
Mes collègues qui pensent que nous sommes seuls
envisagent souvent un obstacle proche :
le bioterrorisme,
le réchauffement climatique, la guerre,
bref, un univers silencieux
parce que la technologie elle-même crée un obstacle
au développement d’une civilisation vraiment avancée.
Voilà une pensée déprimante !
Je pense que c'est l'inverse.
J’ai grandi avec Star Trek et Planète interdite.
J’ai même vu un OVNI.
Donc, cette idée de solitude cosmique me plonge dans la mélancolie.
Néanmoins,
le silence de l’univers crie dans mes oreilles :
« Nous sommes les êtres chanceux. »
On a dépassé tous les obstacles.
On est la seule espèce qui les a vaincus,
la seule espèce capable de déterminer son propre destin.
Si nous apprenons à apprécier le caractère unique de notre planète,
l’importance de prendre soin de notre habitat,
à en trouver d’autres,
et notre chance incroyable d’avoir simplement conscience de l’univers,
l’humanité pourra survivre pendant un certain temps.
Toutes ces choses merveilleuses dont nous rêvons
que les extraterrestres ont pu réaliser un jour
pourraient devenir notre avenir.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)